pentagon officials in the u.s recently
returned an
open verdict on extraterrestrial
visitors to earth
they neither confirmed nor ruled out
their existence
following a military probe into ufos so
on
world ufo day we are asking do they
or don't they exist the truth is
somewhere out there
so they say and we sent our intrepid
correspondent stefan simons
to find it
we're traveling north of las vegas
nevada our destination
area 51 the infamous u.s air force base
that is shrouded in mystery and riddled
with conspiracies
there is somewhat of a hype about all
things ufos
and extraterrestrial in the u.s these
days
following the release of a pentagon
report on ufos
on our way to area 51 on the so-called
extraterrestrial highway we
came across this place here the alien
research center of course it's not
really a research center
it's a gift shop and our luck has it
it's closed closed or not
so-called ufo tourists are stopping by
on one hand fully aware that the alien
research center is only about souvenirs
but on the other hand also open to the
idea
that this is a place for scientific
research on aliens
you never know i mean we are pretty
close to area 51 so
you never you never know it is this you
never know
that inherent doubt many people have
created by perhaps unwarranted secrecy
that is the problem for people like
retired navy pilot lieutenant commander
alex dietrich
we meet her in boulder colorado so i had
this experience in 2004
almost 17 years ago that experience
dietrich is referring to is known as the
nimitz incident
it shows what dietrich and three of her
colleagues encountered off the coast of
san diego california
it is just one of dozens of encounters
by other pilots
they are all categorized as unidentified
aerial phenomena or uap
meaning the pentagon has no explanation
for them and kept them secret for years
dietrich proposes a different approach i
would hope to contribute to the
reductions
of stigma and to promoting
or encouraging a a
deliberate and and thorough
collection and reporting process so that
those individuals who are qualified to
make the analysis
have the information that they need and
that they can conduct that
thorough investigation and analysis to
come up with some conclusion
dietrich's plea for scientifically
standardized data collection on uap
is designated an absolute must in the
future by nasa research scientist ravi
kumar koparapu
from a scientist's perspective my take
on the ufos
is we don't know what they are we cannot
uh speculate what they are without
having
proper data collected on them to find
out uh the nature of these ufos
and my hope is uh we would focus on the
science part of the scientific study of
ufos
and avoid any speculation and be
agnostic
about investigating them back on the
extraterrestrial highway in nevada
we finally arrive at area 51.
even if this u.s air force base will
perhaps never reveal its secrets
most experts and serious minds agree
when it comes to ufos
we simply don't know what we don't know
but
we should look into it